avant d'accueillir la grande star qui va
donner le coup d'envoi de touche pas à
mon poste
j'aimerais qu'on accueille celui qui a
commis l'irréparable cet été jean michel
maire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas si mal
mieux ça ira tous les jours un peu mieux
a expliqué j'ai fait des cheveux parce
que j'ai quand même un droit de le
respecte le public et c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois je me regardais des
happenings dès que je me levais j'avais
un groupe a derrière ce cas c'est comme
un 58 ans jeudi la clinique m'a rappelé
aux mises en faucon par shave l'oeuvre
donc revient cet été
c'est un honneur alors là ils ont ils
ont ils ont pas par cheveux rasé les
cheveux après attendre que ça repousse
donc j'ai fait le maximum à raison d'un
centimètre et demi en moyenne par mois
un mois j'aimerais bien ça sera pas mal
c'est quelque chose quand même
c'est bizarre ça arrangerait je
reconnais gens c'est bizarre mais ça a
son petit succès mais il y en a qui
s'appelait mais je reconnais que moi je
me préfère un piège que jean-michel les
téléspectateurs veulent savoir
j'imagine on m'a dit mais j'ai envie de
me disais la vérité on m'a dit que vous
n'étiez plus célibataire
pardon monsieur voir quoi aulas bon vous
n'êtes plus célibataire
pas du tout vous avez pris cela faire
mes oreilles non je ne suis plus n'est
plus célibataire jean michel maire je
vous le dis et ton nom
[Applaudissements]
est ce que jean michel maire est en
couple oui la table c'est elle le sait
maintenant là et vous avez dit et là
quand je vous vois je sais qu'il vous
aime pour vous la personne ne sait pas
c'est une belle personne on ne connaît
pas la victime
[Rires]
je remercie de confinement est ce que ça
a eu des effets très désagréable pour
tout le monde mais moi elle est venue
habiter chez moi pour le confinement pas
ce que je vais proposer ce qu'elle avait
des appartements il faisait chaud etc
mais vous n'avez pas la clim ou même
j'ai une petite terrasse et puis voilà
qu'elle avait un chien j'ai mon chien
ils feront qu pas que ça et nous on
était copains aussi depuis quelques
années et puis on a appris à se
découvrir et puis chemin faisant à mèche
avec une chambre maintient les
ventilateurs
on a prédit que vous voulez on est y en
a franchi la fredzone et on est venu à
moi et m'a aidé non mais je comprends
bien parce que tout le monde m'a dit tu
vas voir il va t'attaquer et tout est en
fait on va t'attaquer gfa berger
allemand alors qu'est ce que vous avez
dit non il est vraiment rester distant
partira du coup je comprends bien au
prix sia est célibataire donc je vous le
dis
voilà sim mon père soit prescillia et
célibataire sûr que tu la connais bien
je pense que c'est peut-être le moment
c'est quoi le portrait robot et c'est
vrai c'est quoi porterait non mais je
vais être là pour l'instant c'est petit
blond marinière non franchement laid je
suis dégoûté des mecs mais juste un mec
gentil alors que d'écouter des mecs
pendant combien d'heures savoir est-ce
que alors c'est ça c'est fois à chaque
fois qu'on demande à les meufs qu'est ce
qu'elle recherche chez un mec elle dit
un mec gentil et après elle avec le plus
grand at elle dit c'est parce qu'il est
trop gentil voilà exactement ça mignot
faut pas être non plus un canard mais en
même temps il est en même temps il fait
gilles ya quand même sophie cost dans le
public à dire un mec riche un ouais quoi
ça mon critère seront 1 m ission bien
non m'arrêter ou de manière plus rigoler
on a bien gentil riches rich jean
thierry chiche bourse pour vous allez me
[ __ ] mag a encore rappelé
[Applaudissements]